regarding the Duke of York he is going
to face a civil sex case trial after a
U.S judge dismissed a motion by his
legal team to have this lawsuit thrown
out let's get reaction our U.S
correspondent Martha Kellner who has
been following this case is on the phone
for us now Martha what are the next
steps
yeah well this case is now going to
trial it will happen September this year
at the earliest but the key findings
from from Judge Lewis Kaplan he's issued
a 46-page judgment today saying that
he's refusing to throw out the civil
case brought by Virginia's you Frey
against prince Andrew as a reminder
Virginia
claims she was trafficked around the
world by Jeffrey Epstein and the
convicted now sex trafficker Elon
Maxwell she says that on numerous
occasions she was forced to have sex
with prince Andrew claims that he denies
Prince Andrew's lawyers have tried
um on more than one occasion to get
these this case thrown out and the
latest attempt was based on a a an
agreement that Virginia's ufraid had
made with Jeffrey Epstein in 2009 a
settlement
um in which she's received 500 000 this
settlement
um appeared to to refer to other
potential defendants and Prince Andrew's
argument was that she agreed not to
bring any future cases against other
potential
um defendants but judge Lewis Kaplan
um in his in his judgment today has said
that
that wording was reasonably susceptible
to more than one interpretation he said
it cannot be said to demonstrate clearly
and unambiguously that it was to benefit
prince Andrew and so that case will now
go to trial
um at the earliest September this year
but possibly later than that but
certainly not the Judgment that prince
Andrew and his lawyers were hoping for